NEALEIGH MITCHELL: I'm
really excited to introduce
Samorn Selim today.
She is here to discuss
your personal brand,
why it's important, and
what you can do with it.
Samorn Selim is the founder
of Samorn Selim Coaching.
As a coach,
counselor, and lawyer,
Samorn provides a
holistic approach
to coaching professionals,
recent graduates, and students,
including women,
people of color,
and first-generation
professionals.
She has worked with
over 1,000 clients
to assess their career goals,
develop effective job search
strategies, and manage their
professional development.
She's committed to and involved
in diversity and inclusion
initiatives and is a frequent
featured speaker and moderator
at professional
associations on hot topics,
such as managing
cultural code-switching,
supporting first-generation
professionals,
sponsoring women of color, and
developing leadership skills.
She has provided pro
bono legal services
helping refugees, children,
and elderly dependents
and pro bono career
coaching services
for first-generation
professionals, women of color,
and other diverse groups.
Let's join in welcoming
Samorn Selim to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
SAMORN SELIM: Thank
you, Nealeigh.
Raise your hand if you
wake up feeling every day,
I can't wait to be my
awesome self at work.
I hear a lot of chuckle.
Now, raise your hand if you
want to wake up feeling,
I can't wait to be my
awesome self at work.
Awesome.
I've got everybody on there.
Welcome to Authentically
You-- Taking
Charge of your Personal Brand.
And before we dive
into the program,
I want to take a moment
to thank a few people who
made this happen--
Nealeigh Mitchell, Kelsey
Buncher, and Emily Swarts
for making this happen.
I know you guys are
really busy, and the fact
that you're taking this
initiative to put this
together means a lot.
So if you guys can stand
up, and if we can just
give them a round of
applause for their hard work.
[APPLAUSE]
And then, I also want to thank
Google for providing this.
I think it's amazing
that a company as great
as Google, that's known to be
one of the greatest employers,
is still continuing to
invest in its employees
by providing the space and the
resources to make this happen.
So if we can just give Uncle
Google a big round of applause,
too.
[APPLAUSE]
And I also want
to take this time
to acknowledge each
and every one of you
for coming live and also
connecting via live stream.
I know all of you
are incredibly busy.
I was just hearing about your
long commutes for some of you.
And you could be out there
taking pictures with the iBOT
or going to the gym.
And the fact that you're
here says a lot about you
and your commitment
to your career.
So a big round of
applause for you.
[APPLAUSE]
And I want to take
this opportunity
to do something that, I think,
we often don't do, especially
for people who are high
performers like yourselves.
That's the reason why you're
at a great organization
like Google.
So I want you to
trust me with this.
If you can raise your
hands really wide--
and while you're at
it, try not to talk
to the person on the
right or the left--
and just to give yourself a big
hug and say, I'm so awesome.
I couldn't hear you.
Let's do it together
again one more time.
1, 2, 3-- I'm so awesome.
Yeah, and that's just a
great reminder for yourself.
I love seeing the smiles.
Just that can give
you so much energy.
I think sometimes when we're in
the busy of doing and getting
things done, you forget to
acknowledge how amazing you are
and how far you've come.
So if you just have this
practice once a day,
maybe first thing in the
morning, that will really help
jump-start your day.
So when I started my career--
I struggled very much
in my career.
I had this mentality that I have
to put my head down and work
really hard and
be humble and not
bother anybody because
everybody is really busy.
Who can relate to this?
It's everybody in the room.
Everybody is really busy.
And I was the first in my
family to go to college
and to go to
professional school.
So I didn't really have anybody
I could talk to, to say hey,
I'm running into this issue.
How can I solve that?
So I became known for being
really reliable, really
dependable.
And that was great because
I got a lot of good work.
How many can relate to that--
that the reward of good work
is more work?
It's everybody in this room.
They're like,
yeah, that happens.
But on the flip
side what was not
so great about having that
reputation was that on Fridays
at 9:00 PM, when there
was an urgent project,
guess who got a call?
Me.
And I'm assuming a lot of
you are also in that shoes,
as well.
Right-- where you're the ones
who are known to be reliable
and so you're getting this call?
And so what happens is it
creates a really frustrating
environment where you're
feeling tired and overworked
and underappreciated
because people are so busy,
they forget to thank you or
to really acknowledge you
for your contributions.
And at the same
time, what I saw is
that when it came time
for raises and promotions,
I wasn't necessarily getting the
best raises or best promotions.
And a big part of that was
because I kept my head down.
I didn't talk to anybody, and I
didn't want to bother anybody.
So nobody knew that
I was doing anything,
other than that I
was getting things
done when they needed it done.
And so I found myself in
a place where I was really
frustrated and exhausted and
just really wondering what
I was going to do in my career.
How many of you at some point in
your career can relate to that?
It's almost everybody in here.
And it wasn't until I worked
with a leadership coach
where she helped me to question
my assumptions and my values
and what it meant to be humble,
what it meant to be authentic,
and what it meant
to be a hard worker
and then to devise some
key strategies where I made
some small changes
in the way I interact
with people that had
a huge impact-- that I
was able to see my life
and my career transform.
And I was so
inspired by the work
that she was able to do with me.
And that inspired me
to become a coach.
And now, I have the
privilege of being
able to help my clients go
from being stuck or frustrated
or waking up with
dread or maybe feeling
a little bored at work-- to
go from that space to being
at a place where they're getting
that dream job that they want,
to go into that space where they
wake up excited to go to work.
And they're getting
the promotions
and raises that they so worked
hard for and deserve, and most
importantly, to be happy.
And I'm really
excited to be here
to share those
strategies with you.
We have a short, now, 45
minutes together because I
know we started a little late.
So I'm going to give
you my best stuff,
but I also know that we won't
be able to cover everything.
I will try to reserve
a little bit of time
afterwards for questions.
And we'll hang out
afterwards if you
have questions that you don't
want to ask in the audience
and want to ask privately.
And if you have
questions beyond that,
feel free to always email me at
samorn@samornselimcoaching.com.
I do read every email
that comes through.
So what we're going
to cover today
is what is your personal brand.
Why does your
personal brand matter?
How does authenticity fit
with your personal brand?
And then, with all
that information,
what do you want to do
with that personal brand?
So what is the personal brand?
Anybody recognize who that is?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
SAMORN SELIM: Yeah?
Yeah, somebody raise their hand.
Awesome.
Who is that person?
AUDIENCE: Oprah.
SAMORN SELIM: Oprah.
Yes, everybody recognizes Oprah.
So when you see
Oprah-- her picture--
or hear her name, what
are some words that you
associate with her?
AUDIENCE: Success.
SAMORN SELIM: Success.
What else?
AUDIENCE: Confident.
SAMORN SELIM: Confident.
AUDIENCE: She's loved.
SAMORN SELIM: What was that?
AUDIENCE: She's loved
by other people.
People like her.
SAMORN SELIM: Yeah, she's loved.
Yeah, she's loved.
So what is the consistent
theme that you're
hearing in the words that
are being described to Oprah?
Would you say it's positive,
negative, or neutral?
AUDIENCE: Positive.
SAMORN SELIM: Positive.
Oprah has a very
strong personal brand.
And if you know
her backstory, she
started from very
humble beginnings.
But she had a strong
vision about who she was
and what she stands for.
And now, she's been able to
build this amazing empire
where, in a moment's notice,
she can put you on her book club
list and go from an unknown
author to being a "New York
Times" bestseller overnight.
Now, some of you might
say, well, that's cool,
but that's Oprah.
What does that
have to do with me?
Similarly, in your
own career, if you
have a strong
personal brand, you
can really have the ability
to make things happen
and to help accelerate
your career.
Or if you have a negative
association with your brand,
guess what?
That could also prevent you
from being able to be promoted
or being able to get to work
on projects that you might want
to have or even being able
to have good relationships
with your coworkers.
So that's the value of a brand.
And I want to bring
up an example of one
of my recent clients.
One of my recent clients
that I worked with
is an attorney who
works at a tech company.
How many attorneys
are in the room?
I think one person in the back.
Any engineers in the room?
We've got all engineers.
I love it.
It's going to be like the
fight battle between engineers
and lawyers.
So a common story that I hear
from my engineering clients
is I really hate talking
to those lawyers.
Who can relate to that?
I think everybody, right?
They're roadblockers.
They don't understand
the technology.
And it's really a waste of time.
So that's a common response
I hear from my engineering
clients.
And then, on the
other hand, what
I hear from my lawyer
clients is those engineers,
they're really smart.
They're so brilliant.
They make amazing
products, but they
have no clue how they're
screwing our company
for millions and
gazillions of dollars
because they won't ever
talk to us when they're
doing these licensing deals.
Or they won't patent
these projects.
And so this is a common
conversation that goes on
between these two clients.
It's funny because I get to sit
behind closed doors with them,
and I'm like, wow, this comes
up almost every single instance.
And so what happens is there's
a cat and mouse game where
an issue comes up,
lawyer calls engineer,
engineer avoids lawyer, and that
loop kind of goes on-- creates
a very frustrating situation.
And we have basically
zero productivity,
and in fact, what I argue
is negative productivity
because who would be
frustrated in that?
How many of you would
be frustrated with that?
I see everybody.
Almost everybody's hand's up.
Yes, it's a
frustrating situation.
So what you end
up with is energy
where you're spending
a lot of time
being frustrated with each
other and not a lot gets done.
And then, something
big might go wrong
because you're
not communicating.
There is a
communication breakdown.
So this particular
client went in knowing
that this is something
that typically happens.
And so what we devised in
terms of a strategy for him
was instead of approaching
the engineers only
when there was a problem with
the legal issues to actually go
and get to know the engineers.
So this lawyer went to a
lot of the brainstorms.
Sometimes he understood
what's going on,
sometimes he was like, I
don't know what this is.
But he made friends
when he was there.
And what he would do is
invite these engineers
to go to coffees or
to go to lunches.
And through this
process, what he
was able to do is ask
them about their lives
actually care about them as a
human being-- how about that,
right-- and then ask them,
what are you working on?
What's going on there?
And point blank say, what can I,
as a lawyer, and our legal team
do to support you and
to better communicate
with you because we're really
here to partner with you.
And we really want to help you.
And through that process and
through consistent-- and this
is the key-- consistent
interactions in this way,
he was able to develop a really
strong relationship with them.
And so instead now, when
he calls the engineers,
they actually pick
up his phone call.
And instead of being
seen as a roadblocker,
he's actually seen
as a true partner.
And what's also really
interesting is that now when
the engineers have problems,
they actually call him and say,
hey, we're running
into this issue.
Do you think you
can give us a hand?
And so through those
positive associations
with his personal brand,
he was able to transform it
from a negative
association of being
a negative roadblocker to
being somebody who's positive
and a true partnership.
And so he's able to,
in his day-to-day life,
decrease frustration and
increase productivity
and have more time to be able
to revel in the successes
that he has.
And how does that
benefit his career?
His supervisors now
know him as somebody
who is a problem solver,
who can connect with others.
And so he becomes
a go-to person when
the legal team needs to work
with the engineering team.
And you can see that it's
a win-win for everybody.
So that's pretty amazing-- the
power of your personal brand.
So what I'd love for us to do
right now is to do an exercise.
And in this exercise, often what
people forget to think about
is how our perceptions of
what's going on actually
impacts our interaction.
So what I want you
to do is to trust me,
is to close your eyes.
Make sure nobody pokes
you from the side.
And if somebody does, I'll
go and hit their hand.
And so to think
of some colleagues
that you have that you work
with, either in your group
or outside of your
group, and then
to pick one person in mind.
And if that person
had to describe
you using three adjectives, what
are the three adjectives that's
coming to mind?
And I want you to sit with those
adjectives for the next 5 to 10
seconds-- a little
uncomfortable--
but I want you to
feel what that feels
like when you hear those
adjectives about yourselves.
Now, I want you
to open your eyes.
And on your handout, write down
what those three adjectives
are in the section that's
What is Your Personal Brand.
So what we're going to do
now is partner activity.
I want you to find a partner A,
and-- find a partner, hopefully
somebody you don't
talk to regularly
because the purpose of
these types of conversations
is really to meet
somebody else, as well.
So find a partner.
Go ahead.
Pair up.
If you're on the right
side-- my right side,
you'll be partner A.
If you're partner A,
can you raise your hand?
And then, if you're
on the left side,
you'll be partner B. And if
you're doing front and back,
the person in front will be
A, and the person in back
will be B.
So if you're A's, can
you raise your hand?
OK, so A's, in this exercise,
what we're going to do
is you're going to get a chance
to tell your partner what
the three adjectives
are and what
feelings came up for
you as you were thinking
about these adjectives.
And B, what you're going to do
is practice active listening.
What that means is
you don't get to talk.
You don't get to ask questions.
You actually don't
even get to make noise.
You can nod your head, but
the idea is to really listen.
And if there is an
awkward silence,
sit in that awkwardness.
But allow A to really describe
what's going on for them.
OK, so your two
minutes starts now.
[CHATTER]
So I felt a lot of
energy and positivity
and saw a lot of smiles.
So that's good.
So now, B, you did such an
awesome job being a listener.
Guess what?
It's your turn to get to share.
And A, likewise,
please sit in silence
and let the other person
just express their feelings.
And if there's awkwardness
in the silence, it's OK.
Just let them keep going.
So your two minutes,
B, starts now.
[CHATTER]
Wow.
So it sounds like there was a
lot of energy and enthusiasm
and sharing.
And what I'd love to hear
is what came up for you?
What were some of
the adjectives?
How did it feel to
actually share what
those adjectives made you feel?
And what was it like to
be on the listening side?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
SAMORN SELIM: Do you mind
sharing what those two are?
AUDIENCE: The plus--
taking initiative
and being very helpful.
SAMORN SELIM: OK,
taking initiative
and being very helpful-- so
very positive associations.
And when you thought
about that about yourself,
how did that make you feel?
AUDIENCE: All right.
SAMORN SELIM: All right?
He's like, meh.
And that's actually
a common experience
that I get is a lot of
people often don't take time
to really think
about the assumptions
that they make
about other people
and how those people
are perceiving them.
And often, the
assumptions that we
think that other people
are making about us
often are not as positive as
what those other people might
be thinking because we tend
to be our worst critics.
I'd love to hear a
couple more shares.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
I think I had
much more positive association
as far as what my [INAUDIBLE]
about myself versus my
partner had a little bit more
of a negative
assumption of himself.
So that's also [INAUDIBLE].
SAMORN SELIM: OK.
So you thought it
was interesting
that you had a more positive
association of yourself
and your partner had a
more negative association.
AUDIENCE: Maybe it's more
self-aware or critical.
SAMORN SELIM: More
self-aware, more critical.
What was it that you found
interesting about it?
AUDIENCE: That [INAUDIBLE].
SAMORN SELIM: Yeah, yeah.
And you know here's why
these associations are
really important--
it's that if you have
a positive perception that
somebody else thinks you're
a good person or easy to work
with, when you see that person,
are you more likely to
engage with that person?
Thumbs up, yeah.
Thumbs down, no.
Mostly thumbs up.
Yes.
Now, on the flip side, if
your partner might think,
I don't think that
person really likes me,
or it's difficult to
work with that person.
When you see that
person, are you
going to want to
engage with them?
No.
So this is the
power of perception
about your own personal brand.
And this is often
a critical piece
that people don't think about is
what are the assumptions that's
underlying that is impacting
our interactions with others?
And I'll share a really--
a good example of this
is one of my clients--
I worked with her,
and she's really amazing.
Across the board with her
peers and her subordinates,
she's seen as somebody who's
really amazing, wonderful
to work with.
How many of you know amazing
colleagues like that?
It's everybody.
It's Google-- of course
you've got to know
at least one person like that.
But the thing is that she was
being passed up for promotions
and raises all the time.
We're like, huh?
That's odd.
Why are you being
passed up all the time?
I don't get this.
You're really fantastic.
And what we uncovered was that
she never talked to her boss.
And the only time she
talked to her boss
was when there was a
crisis or something urgent.
Does that sound
familiar to everybody?
Any hands?
Yeah, a lot of head
nods like, yeah.
So now, I want you to
imagine if you were her boss
and you saw her trotting
down the hallway-- hey, boss.
Are you going to
want to talk to her?
No, because she's basically
the crisis problem person.
Right?
So you've just had this very
negative association with her.
And she also has this
very negative association
with her boss-- he's
always frustrated with me.
So when she goes in, she's not
her awesome, authentic self
because her awesome, authentic
self is somebody who's social,
who gets along with people,
who wants to be helper.
But when she goes to
her boss, because she
has this association that
he finds her annoying
or she's disrupting
him or bother him,
she just freezes up.
And the only thing
she goes to him
is like, hey, we
have this problem.
Can we solve it?
It's not making for a
really good relationship.
I see a lot of laughs out there.
People are like,
yeah, that happens.
And it's easy to
imagine that happening
because we're all so busy.
So what I would
challenge you to do,
and what we did
with our client was,
hey, when you're having
your one-on-one meetings
with your boss, which happened
every two weeks for her,
is to not only go
in and be like,
hey, here are the five problems.
What are we going to do?
That doesn't set up a
very good relationship.
And some of you may
want to write this down,
but the key steps that we put
in place that really helped her
transform her relationship was
how about we start with, hey,
how's it going?
Pretty normal, right?
And that's actually something
she does with all of her peers
as well as the people
that she supervises.
It's a 10 second
interaction where
you can humanize yourself.
And then, the second
step that we did
was to also share what were the
things that were going well.
I cannot imagine that in your
workspace that only the sky is
falling, and you're
only having problems.
There are things
that are going well,
but we often forget to mention
the things that are going well
because it's not
urgent on our mind.
But it's still really important
to mention those amazing things
that are going on because, by
doing so, your supervisor can
know that you're actually
getting these things done.
And you're also
reminding them, hey, I'm
doing a really good job
here because we're busy.
And so if you don't
remind them of that,
they're going to forget.
Or they're not going
to be aware that you're
doing that good job.
And then, after you present
those positive things and say,
I think we should keep doing
these things because it's
working, then go
into the challenges.
So what you've done
there is you've
set up a positive association.
So every time that you're
going into the office,
he's not going to
be like, let me duck
and hide because all you're
coming to me with is problems.
And here's the key thing when
you go to your supervisor
with challenges-- come
up with a few solutions.
Maybe the solution isn't
I have the answer that's
going to fix all of this.
But at least have, here are
some two or three things
that I think we could research.
Or here are some
people I think we
could talk to help solve this.
So then, what you do is
you change the association
that your supervisor has
as you're the problem,
big crisis person
to you're the person
who's going to come and share
some good news that I can also
then share with my supervisors
as well because I love to share
how well our department is
doing and how well my people are
doing.
And if you come to
me with problems,
I know that you're also
being very proactive.
And like you, over
there, you're somebody
who's taking initiative.
So you can see how your own
biases about what people
are thinking about
you can impact
your interaction with them
and impact your career.
Now, on the flip side,
what I want to then go into
is why does your
personal brand matter?
Anybody know who that is?
Yeah, who's that?
I get a lot of laughter.
Does everybody know what
"Game of Thrones" is?
It's only half the room?
I can't believe this--
unfathomable to me
that you don't know.
So I'm a geek.
I'm a nerd.
And I love reading about dragons
and all these other things.
But just to give high-level
overview-- "Game of Thrones"
is a book fantasy
series that has
been turned into an HBO series.
And this is one of my favorite
characters, Tyrion Lannister.
Tyrion is born into this
very powerful Lannister
family, which is
fortunate and unfortunate.
His father really hates
him and so does his sister.
But we won't get into
this particular story.
So Tyrion, in the middle
of the book series,
finds himself in this
really interesting position
where he's been asked by his
father to be the king's hand.
And he has to advise the king,
his nephew, on strategies
on how to keep the
country growing.
And as many of you know who've
been following the series,
there are all these wars that
are breaking out everywhere.
Everybody is trying
to be the king.
So Tyrion finds
himself in a place
where King's Landing is
confronted with a battle,
and they are about to lose
this battle to the enemy.
But because Tyrion is
so smart and so witty,
he comes up with an ingenious
plan and, with courage,
tries to fight to the death.
And what we find is
that he actually helps
saves the country
from being taken over.
So now you think, oh, well,
if he's done that of course
he's going to get all
these accolades, right?
No.
What happens is his
father-- because his father
has this perception that Tyrion
is basically not reliable,
is somebody who drinks
too much, and somebody
who gets under his skin and is
the cause of his wife's death
and has all these negative
associations about Tyrion.
What he does, in fact, is he
actually takes all the power
away from Tyrion, dismisses him,
and, to add salt to the wound,
takes his lover.
I know.
It's very tragic.
And this is what can happen
if you're not paying attention
to your brand.
So we know how your own
perception of your association
to your brand, how
others perceive you,
might impact your interaction.
Now, the other piece
of your personal brand
is how other people
actually see you.
And so if the person who
is in charge of your career
giving you raises or promotion
or giving you projects--
or even if they're not, but
they're supposed to help you
as a colleague to get things
done, if they don't have a very
positive association with you,
no matter how hard you work,
no matter how long
the hours you put in,
no matter how great
your accomplishments,
you could end up like Tyrion
where you're not going
to be acknowledged for that.
And that's a tragedy
because obviously somebody
who is saving the country from
being taken over by the enemy
should really get that accolade.
And we don't want that
to have happen to you,
but we see this
time and time again.
How many of you can relate
to that where you're like,
why is that person
getting a promotion?
I don't understand
what they're doing.
A lot of head nods.
A lot of laughter here.
Or I've been here until
midnight every day.
Anybody know that I'm alive?
Why are you supplying
stuff to me?
Lots of hands that
can relate to that.
And so that's the reason
why is that when--
if somebody who is in
charge or who is there
to collaborate with
you-- if they don't have
a strong sense of your
brand, they're also not going
to be there to promote you.
And so now you
recognize how important
it is to have a
strong personal brand
and to manage it because
you can see that it
could impact your career.
But why is there
resistance to it?
There is often a resistance
to it because people--
the most common response I get
is I don't want to be fake.
How many of you have
that natural aversion
to think about your brand and be
like, I don't want to be fake?
I think some of you.
And what I would
encourage you to do
is think about
Oprah's lesson where
she says, "I can be a
much better Oprah than I
could be a pretend Barbara."
And the reference is to this--
when Oprah started her career
as an anchorwoman,
the person she admired
most was Barbara Walters.
And what she would do
would study Barbara and try
to mimic her when she's on TV.
And that was really exhausting.
And it wasn't until
there was a moment where
she screwed something up and
just kind of laughed and let
out a sigh of relief
that it hit her.
And there was a moment
where a light bulb went off,
and she said, you know what?
It's much better to be me
than to be a pretend Barbara.
And that was when
her career took off.
So what I would
encourage you to do
in thinking about
your personal brand
is really not about making
this where you have to be fake
or you have to kiss up or
you have to change yourself
so drastically so that you
don't remember who you are
because that would
be really exhausting
to wear a mask every day.
What I am encouraging you to do
is to take a look and say, hey,
what is going on with
my personal brand
about my own assumptions?
And how are other people
really perceiving me,
and is that something
I'm happy with?
And if that's not, what
are some small things
that I can do to make
some big changes?
So you know I've worked with
a lot of introverts and people
who are humble and shy.
How many of you relate to being
an introvert, humble, or shy?
3/4 of the room-- OK, almost
everybody in the room.
And often when I talk
to them about this,
there's this I just
feel like it's too much
or I just can't do
it right or I just
don't want to change myself.
And what I would
encourage you to do
is to not make this huge leap.
I'm not asking you to
go from this person who
is more shy and reserved to
being like, hey, everybody.
I'm the life of the
party, but to really take
some small steps that
can actually make
a big impact on your career.
And here's an
example of where you
can make that big difference.
I was working with a client
where he's really bright.
He's really great
at what he does,
but he's not-- but when you
ask who he is in the company,
everybody is kind
of like, who's that?
And it's because
he's keeping himself
really small and really quiet.
And so some of
the things that we
did for him to help him change
his own perception of himself,
but also to help others
see that his brand is
something that is strong and
something that's positive
that should be associated with,
is to make some minor changes.
So for example, when he goes
to the cafeteria to get water
or goes to a meeting to
just actually say, hey,
how's it going to the
person standing around him.
It's a little awkward at first,
but it's just that initial step
because everybody's
feeling a little awkward.
And so that's one thing.
So just by doing
that, he was actually
able to get to know people
and people knew his name.
So that was an
amazing feat for him.
So after a month of doing that
and feeling more confidence
because he's like, hey,
I didn't die from that.
People actually said, hi, back.
It was amazing.
What we then did
was say, OK, what
can we do now to up your
game just a little bit more?
So his interaction with people
are, hey, how's it going?
Good.
How's it going?
OK, that was good
as initial step,
but it didn't really
allow room for rapport.
So the next thing that we added
to his assignment was to say,
what's one thing you
can say about the work
that you're doing that you
can share with somebody else
that you love
because when you're
positive and excited
and being authentically
sharing about what you love,
it spreads joy to everybody.
So we added to
his assignment was
to come up with one thing every
week that he wanted to share.
So the interaction became,
hey, how's it going?
Good-- been working
on this feature,
and I'm super excited to
hear the feedback on it.
The reception to that
was a lot more positive,
and it actually opened
the space to have a longer
conversation, which was,
what's the feature about,
blah, blah, blah.
And so it really allowed him to
go more into what he was doing
and to share that passion.
And over time, by
consistently doing that,
people in his company were
actually able to know his name
and also know what he
brought to the table
and, more importantly, have a
positive association with him
because he was actually
excited about the work
that he was doing as opposed
to being known as the guy who
never talked to anybody, who
didn't care, and didn't seem
like he was invested
in the company.
Can you see the big difference
that that small thing can make?
I see a lot of head nods.
Yes.
And so that's what we're
hoping that you can do today
is to find the things that are
authentically true to you--
that you're excited about,
that you're happy about,
the things that you're
working on that are good,
and to share in a way that
honors your contributions
but also uplifts
everybody around you.
It doesn't have to be this
experience that's negative
or that is fake.
And by doing so-- the
good thing about that
is that when there's
an issue involving
that particular project or
that particular assignment,
the first person
they might think
about calling to help
solve that problem,
if that issue comes up, is you.
And so what we're doing
is creating value for you,
but we're also creating
value for other team members
and then overall productivity
for the organization.
So now, you know what
a personal brand is.
It's an immediate
association that people
have about you when they
think of you or hear
of you, similar to
what we saw with Oprah.
You see the positive
consequences
it can have in your career, like
the lawyer that I was talking
about, or the really
negative consequences it
can have in your career, like
my favorite character, Tyrion
Lannister.
And you see that you can be
authentic in your own way
and still manage
your personal brand.
So the next question
is, well, what
do you want to do with that?
What I find is that a lot of
times people go back and say,
well, I'm inspired
for a day, and I'm
going to do something and
then kind of drop off.
What I would encourage you to do
is to be consistent about this.
So three things that
I would recommend
that you do that can make
a big change is, one,
go back and do the exercise
we did earlier, which
is to think about the people
that you're interacting
with on a regular
basis and ask yourself,
what do you think they're
thinking about you?
And how does that impact
your interactions with them?
The second thing is to
actually go out and ask
a few coworkers about that.
What are the three
key adjectives
that comes to mind
when you think of me?
What do you think
are my strengths?
And what would you
like to see more of?
This can be scary because you're
being vulnerable and putting
out yourself out
there, but this is also
a moment of
transformation because
without that information,
it's really hard
to assess where you
are and whether you
want to make changes.
And then, the last
piece is this--
with that information, what
are you going to do about it?
Are you going to go home
and say, you know what?
That's cool, but I'm not
interested in making changes.
Or you can make that decision
to put things in your calendar.
And all it really takes
is 15 minutes a week
to make these changes
so that you can better
manage your personal brand.
And I know that with
change it's always scary,
even if it's good for you.
And it reminds me
of a story of myself
when I was in college--
that was a long time ago.
And I was in my senior
year of college.
I got an interview at this
tech company that, at the time,
was really up-and-coming.
And I was so excited.
I was researching the company.
I was practicing my pitch.
I made a list of 10
questions so that I
wouldn't be stumped at the end.
I crossed the T's
and dotted the I's.
And I was like, I'm
ready for this interview.
So I'm jotting
into the interview,
and I was super excited.
So the guy says, hi, and we
kind of chit-chat a little bit--
a little talk.
He goes into the spiel about
his company over the next 15
minutes.
He answers every single
question that's on my list.
And then, he says, what do
you want to know about us?
I could not come
up with anything.
I was completely stumped.
So the question I asked-- and
I'm still embarrassed about
it-- is, is it true that your
company offers good free food?
Take a guess at what that
company was-- Google.
Yeah, and I was mortified.
It stayed with me for a
while-- like, oh my god.
They must think I'm the
most awful interview ever.
And it's not a great question.
And it was embarrassing.
And it was hard to
actually share it out loud.
And I share this story because I
think that that situation could
have stayed with me and derailed
me and kept me in a place
where I'm like,
oh, I'm never going
to talk to Googlers ever again.
I'm never going to do
anything here again.
And fast forward
years later-- I'm
now being invited to come back
and give this presentation
to you and to have
this honor of being
able to share, through
my own personal trials
and tribulations and through
the trainings that I've got
and through the
experiences I've had
in helping over 1,000 clients,
to now be able to give you
these strategies.
And I share that story because
I can assure you, all of you
have jobs at Google.
So you're definitely
10 steps ahead of me.
You at least got through
the screening round, got
through the callbacks-- and I
know the interview process here
is really long.
And you're way ahead
of me when I started.
So if I can go from that
place to being where I am now,
I am more than confident
that, with consistent work
with these strategies,
that you will
be able to have a really
amazing, successful career
and that, at this point, if
you make that choice to choose
to change your personal brand
in a positive direction,
you can definitely
make that happen.
So it was with great
honor to be here,
and I just really want
to humbly thank you
for spending this time together.
And I'll take
questions after this.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: So what if
your personal perception
of yourself and other
coworkers are different?
SAMORN SELIM: So that
depends-- great question.
So let's dig a
little bit into that.
Do you feel your personal
perception of yourself
is positive or negative?
AUDIENCE: Positive.
SAMORN SELIM: OK,
and then, do you
think your coworkers'
perception of you
is positive,
negative, or neutral?
AUDIENCE: Still positive,
but just different stuff.
SAMORN SELIM: OK, and so what
I would say with that is it
sounds like you're
in a good place
because you're feeling
pretty good about yourself,
which is the first step.
And your coworkers are
feeling pretty good about you.
And so if what you
want to do is to have
them see more of the stuff
that you're feeling good about,
then the recommendation
would be,
depending on the interactions
you have with people,
to discuss those things more--
to find ways in highlighting
those things more.
So give me a specific
example because it's harder
to answer in the abstract.
So what's a positive
association of yourself that you
want others to know about you?
AUDIENCE: To give
more initiative.
SAMORN SELIM: OK, so if you want
to show that you're somebody
who is taking more
initiative, one of the ways
you can do that is if
you're at a team meeting,
instead of just sitting quiet--
and I'm not saying that's you--
but for the sake of
time, what I would say
is that at every meeting
you should at least make
one comment if you're not making
a comment and asking questions.
And the other thing that you
can do to really show initiative
is if there is something
that's being assigned
or projects that
are coming up, you
would be the person who
would volunteer for it.
And that's showing
initiative right there.
The key thing then,
though, is to follow up,
that when you're working
on these projects
to let people on your team
and let your supervisors
know that, as well.
AUDIENCE: So there is
one school of thought
where they say you keep
doing the good work
and things will fall in place.
And now, there's this
concept of personal brand
where you have to proactively
influence or change
the perception of other people.
You see any conflict?
SAMORN SELIM: No, I don't.
I don't at all.
And I think that's a
really great question.
I think the basis is you
have to do good work.
If you're doing bad work and
you're expecting everybody else
to think good about you, that's
a really hard place to be.
And that would not be something
I would advocate for any client
because I'm really about
having integrity, honesty,
and authenticity.
So you do need to do
consistent good work.
And some things will
fall into place.
So you get a job at Google.
That's things
falling into place.
And Google is an
amazing place to work.
Now, if you want to
elevate yourself and get
to that next stage where
you're going into management
and leadership, there
has to be some changes
in your strategies.
So the foundation
of doing good work
is still a core
foundation of who
you are, but that
extra step of sharing
the good work that you're doing
doesn't take away from that.
It only adds to that.
NEALEIGH MITCHELL:
Thank you very much.
SAMORN SELIM: Thank you, guys.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]